In this video will
we summarize cell breathing.
It may seem like a very intense process,
my charts might look confused,
but are clearer than that,
which actually happens in your cells and organs.
Here we will show how exactly
we can produce ATP from glucose, via glycolysis,
cycle of Krebs
and oxidative phosphorylation.
In fact, any molecules can be involved
in different parts of the process, then go out
from it and to include other metabolic pathways.
Here we will tell
traditional history,
I'll start with glucose.
We have a chain of six carbon atoms.
We also have the process of glycolysis that is going on
in the cytosol of our cells.
If this is a cell here,
we can imagine that glycolysis
this is here.
In the glycolysis process, the glucose molecule,
containing six carbon atoms,
is divided into two molecules with three carbon atoms.
These molecules have three carbon atoms
are called pyruvate.
They're drinking.
In this process
we can produce ATP, which is
the main goal of glycolysis.
We produce four molecules of ATP, and we use two.
We generally win two ATF molecules.
I'll make a table here to track the number of ATP molecules produced.
We produce two molecules of ATP
and in the same time
we reduce two molecules up to NAD.
Remember, in the reduction, we gain electrons.
Here we see that this compound is positively charged,
and this is neutral, it has received a hydride anion.
This is a reduction.
Reducing.
If we go through the whole process and get to
up to oxidative phosphorylation
and the electron transport chain, we will see that NAD is reduced
to NADH, which can then be oxidized,
which will deliver more energy
for the production of ATP.
We will get two molecules NAD.
Two molecules of NAD will be produced.
At this stage, it must be taken
solution.
If there is no oxygen around the body
or for any reason,
he does not want to continue
with cellular breathing, or can not,
this pyruvate will be used for fermentation.
We have videos about fermentation,
lactic acid or alcoholic fermentation,
in the fermentation pyruvate is used,
to oxidize NAD to NAD.
Thus NAD can be used again for glycolysis.
Although NADN has energy,
which can be turned into ATP,
although pyruvate has energy,
in fermentation, we ignore all this
we consider these compounds only as waste products.
We use the pyuva to turn NAD back into the NAD.
Then glycolysis will be able to run again.
But let's assume that the process will not
go to fermentation,
but will continue to the traditional one
aerobic cell breathing that uses oxygen.
The next thing that will happen is,
that this carboxyl group -
Everything I will show now,
will happen to each of these pyruvate molecules.
You can imagine all this repeated twice.
That is why I will multiply the products of the reactions in two.
In the next step,
I have this carboxyl group which,
is detached from the pyruvate and is excreted
in the form of carbon dioxide.
This is the carbon dioxide released.
And the rest of the pyuva
is an acetyl group which is attached to coenzyme A.
You will often hear about coenzyme A.
It is sometimes referred to as CoA,
and sometimes as CoA and then
sulfur bonded to hydrogen.
The reason we draw
the sulfur is that it connects
with the acetyl group here.
So, we have carbon dioxide that separates
and an acetyl group that binds to sulfur,
thus obtaining acetyl-CoA.
With this designation (CoA), we see only acetyl-CoA
three letters,
but in fact it is a very complex molecule.
Here's a drawing of acetyl-CoA.
I know it's very small,
but I hope it shows how complex the molecule is.
The acetyl group we are talking about
here's the part here. This is coenzyme.
Helps to transport this acetyl group,
we will see this in a second.
It is fun to look at these molecules,
because we see the same patterns
over and over again in different parts of biology and biochemistry.
In acetyl-CoA, we have adenine here.
It's hard to see, but we also have ribose,
as well as two phosphate groups.
This end of acetyl-CoA is in practice
ADP.
But it is used as coenzyme.
All I talk about
is assisted by enzymes,
and the enzymes will have
cofactors and coenzymes,
which also help the reactions.
As we can see, the acetyl group is linked
with coenzyme A to form acetyl-CoA,
but this is a temporary connection.
Acetyl-CoA will bring in
acetyl group
in the Krebs cycle.
It will carry these two carbon atoms
to the oxalacetate to give the citrate.
to this molecule having one, two, three, four carbon atoms,
to obtain a molecule of one, two, three, four, five, six carbon atoms.
But before we deepen the Krebs cycle,
I want to make sure that
we do not lose the number
of the produced ATPs and NADNs.
In this step here, in the decarboxylation of pyruvate,
we switched from pyruvate to acetyl-CoA,
we also have a reduction of NAD to NAD.
This will happen with each of the pyruvate molecules.
When Counting Received
ATP and NADH molecules,
we are talking about the resulting, upon decomposition of one molecule of glucose.
From one molecule of glucose we will get two pyruvate molecules
and they will be used in the next steps of the process in the same way.
-
This will be multiplied by two.
We will produce
two molecules NAD in this step,
when we move from pyruvate to acetyl-CoA.
the main part
from the catabolism of organic compounds,
through which we will receive ATP,
is happening in
the Krebs cycle also called the citric acid cycle.
It's called the citric acid cycle because when
transfer the acetyl group of coenzyme A
on the oxalacetate, we get citrate or citric acid.
Citric acid
is found in lemons or orange juice.
This is the molecule here.
The citric acid cycle and the Krebs cycle are the same thing.
When you see it for the first time it looks very complicated
and some people really think that.
But I will summarize the processes in it.
The citric acid, which has six carbon atoms,
continues to break down in the next steps.
Here I do not show all the details.
The citric acid is degraded until it is again converted to oxalacetate.
Then he can accept the two carbon atoms again.
And to make it clear when the two carbon atoms
are released due to coenzyme A,
it can be reused,
to decarboxylate other pyruvate molecules.
There are several cycles that are spinning.
The important thing is that going through
the citric acid cycle, passing from one intermediate product to another,
we redraw molecules up to NAD.
We do this three times each turn
of the citric acid cycle. That will happen
for each acetyl-CoA molecule.
For each pirate.
With one molecule of glucose, it will twist twice.
We'll twist the loop twice
for each molecule of glucose.
Here we have produced one, two three molecules NAD,
but since the cycle will rotate twice,
because we have one
glucose molecule,
we can say we have six
molecules NAD.
Either six NAD molecules are reduced to NAD.
In this process
we're going through the molecule with
six carbon atoms, to a four carbon atom molecule
and release carbon in the form of carbon dioxide.
Normally, we also have GFF conversion
in the GFP or sometimes the ADF in the ATF,
but functional GLP is equivalent to ATP.
-
Remember, all this happens twice for one molecule of glucose.
We can report
two molecules ATP for easier.
We can say GFT, but I'll take it for ATF.
Once again, I repeat that this happens once every turn of the cycle,
but for each glucose molecule, the cycle is rotated twice.
We have another coenzyme here -
FAD, which is reduced to FADN2,
but remains covalently associated with the enzymes,
who support it.
So it's ultimately used to reduce it
coenzyme Q to QH2.
I will write QH2 here.
Since the cycle will rotate twice,
write two on QH2.
Now let's think about the net
profit.
-
I'll write it down abridged.
We will go into more detail in other videos.
These coenzymes, NADH and QH2
will be oxidized
in the oxidative phosphorylation
and the electron transport chain,
to create a proton gradient
on both sides of the inner mitochondrial membrane.
We will explain all this in much more detail in the following videos,
but the proton gradient will be used for
producing more ATP.
To understand this process,
we need to know that every molecule NAD -
I've seen ideas that performance is important
and the location of NADN
will be produced. But thanks to every NAM molecule
we produce between two and three ATP molecules.
Each molecule of the reduced coenzyme Q-
QH2
will be involved in the production of 1.5 molecules of ATP.
Scientists are still up and running
to understand all the details of this process.
Depends on cell efficiency
and what is the purpose of the cage, what it wants to do.
I would often give a space -
between 1.5 and 2 molecules of ATP.
These are approximate calculations.
Think about the general bill.
If we collect all the ATP or GTF molecules,
we will have two here, two here.
We'll have four directly
or nearly directly synthesized ATP molecules.
How many NAD molecules?
We have two, four, and then we add six.
We have ten molecules NAD.
Ten molecules NAN.
Then we have two coenzyme Q molecules.
Two molecules QH2.
Here I have four ATF molecules.
-
We'll get here
between
20 and 30 ATP molecules.
And here, between three and four
ATP molecules.
If we collect them,
if we gather all the lower bounds,
to see - 20 plus three, plus four.
These are 27 molecules of ATP.
27 molecules ATP.
Let's see what we get for the upper limit.
We have four plus 30, plus four.
We get 38.
38 molecules ATP.
38 molecules ATP is considered
for the theoretical maximum that can be synthesized.
But in fact, when monitoring these processes in cells,
it seems to produce around 29-30 ATP molecules.
Again, I will note that these values ​​depend on
what the cage wants, cell type, and efficiency.
All this happens in cellular breathing.
Explain
where these processes are going.
Where does all this happen?
We have said that glycolysis occurs in the cytosol.
The citric acid cycle
flows into the mitochondria.
In this space here
the citric acid cycle proceeds.
In this space stained in the manga.
This is the matrix.
We talk about the mitochondria video
much for him.
And the transformation of coenzymes
and processes in the electron transport chain
flowing into the crystals' membrane.
Christians are creases or crests
in the inner membrane of the mitochondria.
This happens in the membrane
of these critics.
Christa is the only number, the crystalline - the multiple.
We will talk more about this in other videos.